LINKEDIN:
What’s the most powerful social media in
the world?
YouTube?
Instagram?
TikTok?
Well, there’s definitely a strong argument
to be made about each and every one of those
platforms, but I would argue that the most
powerful social media in the world is actually
LinkedIn.
If you’re not familiar with LinkedIn, they’re
a professional networking site owned by Microsoft
where people can share their career progression
with friends, family, and hopefully also recruiters
from potential future employers.
Today, LinkedIn boasts a whopping 950 million
members from more than 200 countries and territories
around the world.
For perspective, WhatsApp has over 2 billion
monthly active users and YouTube has 2.7 billion
monthly active users.
So, LinkedIn is obviously not the most popular
social media platform in the world but when
we look at power, it’s a completely different
story.
Take revenue for example.
In 2022, WhatsApp pulled in a total of $906
million.
This translates to a little less to 50 cents
per user per year.
LinkedIn on the other hand pulled in $14.59
billion in 2022.
This translates to over $15 in revenue per
user per year or over 30 times more than WhatsApp.
Aka, at their current rate, WhatsApp would
need over 60 billion users to pull in the
same revenue as LinkedIn.
Even YouTube only pulls in a little less than
$11 per user per year and a lot of people
spend their entire lives on YouTube.
With LinkedIn, the vast majority of users
just check in here and there.
And the craziest part is that Microsoft didn’t
pay all that much more for LinkedIn than Facebook
paid for WhatsApp.
When all was said and done, Facebook paid
a total of $22 billion for WhatsApp while
Microsoft paid $26.2 billion for LinkedIn.
Microsoft clearly got more bang for their
buck but the power of LinkedIn goes much deeper
than just monetary gain.
Today, LinkedIn is synonymous with not just
professional networking but power, control,
and influence within the corporate world.
Let me explain.
SUPERIOR DEMOGRAPHICS:
Microsoft has clearly built a massive social
media platform behind the scenes, but that’s
not the only they’ve been building.
Over the past 15 years, Microsoft has grown
their cash reserves from $30 to $40 billion
to $130 to $140 billion.
If you’re wondering how such companies responsibly
store and maintain so much cash, well, their
secret is bonds.
Such companies often own tens of billions
if not hundreds of billions of dollars worth
of government and corporate bonds which are
currently yielding 4-7%.
If you look for a modern platform to invest
in bonds yourself, however, you’ll quickly
find yourself with no options and that’s
where our bond investing app, Silo, comes
into play.
With Silo, not only are your deposits and
investments covered by $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance, but all
funds and financial activity is handled by
our trusted custodian, IBKR, who has 45 years
of experience managing over $350 billion worth
of assets.
So, if you want the safety and relability
of an experienced financial institution combined
with the UI and ease of use of a modern tech
company, please consider checking out Silo
in the description below.
But, anyway, taking a look back, the story
of LinkedIn dates back to the early 2000s
to a man named Reid Hoffman.
LinkedIn likes to claim LinkedIn was started
in Reid’s living room and that’s probably
technically true but make no mistake, LinkedIn
was by no means a bootstrapped startup.
Not only did they have a stacked team with
a bunch of early PayPal employees and executives
but they also had access to $123 million worth
of funding over the next several years.
So, you basically had the dream team paired
with virtually unlimited funding, and their
goal was simple: create a business oriented
social media network.
They would call it LinkedIn and LinkedIn would
make its debut on May 5, 2003.
Unlike other social media platforms, LinkedIn
never really had some sort of viral moment
or explosion.
Instagram, for example, racked up 25,000 users
within first day, 100,000 users within the
first week, and a 1,000,000 users within the
first 2 months.
LinkedIn’s growth on the other hand was
a lot more modest.
They ended the first month with 4,500 users
much of whom were invited by the company’s
original employees.
But, overtime, these numbers slowly compounded.
Instead of getting thousands of users per
month, LinkedIn started getting tens of thousands
and then hundreds of thousands and so on.
Likely the main reason that LinkedIn never
had a viral moment was because of their demographics
but at the same time, their unique demographics
are what make the platform so special in the
first place.
Technically, you only have to be 16 years
old to create a LinkedIn account but I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that the
vast majority of LinkedIn users are above
the age of 25.
This is stark contrast to basically any other
social media platform.
With TikTok, for example, 30% of their users
are under the age of 20 and another 30% are
under the age of 30.
YouTube’s users tend to be older but we
also have to keep in mind: what kid doesn’t
just lie about their age?
After all, 5 out of the top 10 most subscribed
YouTubers make content for teenagers and children.
There’s nothing wrong with this as YouTube
and most social media platforms are largely
meant for entertainment.
So, it’s not surprising that younger people
with more time tend to use these platforms
more actively.
But, when we look at from a more cynical perspective
of which userbase is more lucrative and useful
to control, it’s obviously the older demographic.
We should also note that LinkedIn’s userbase
is not only older than other platforms, they’re
also way more successful, at least from career
perspective.
I mean, just think about it, what type of
person would want to publicize their professional
life.
Obviously, not someone who’s a cashier at
Walmart or an Uber Eats delivery driver.
It’s probably not even someone who has a
more modest job as a teacher or police officer
or nurse or even doctor for that matter.
LinkedIn’s most active users are the hyper
competitive type who are playing the game
of capitalism and climbing the corporate ladder.
Aka, the people with the most power, control,
and influence in the world.
By the end of 2004, LinkedIn would grow to
house over a million of these people and that
was just the beginning.
CRYSTAL CLEAR INTENT:
Moving into 2005, LinkedIn would roll out
the first stages of monetizing this highly
valuable user base with the launch of LinkedIn
jobs.
Over the years, this has expanded into 3 primary
sources of revenue starting with talent solutions.
This is by far their largest source of revenue.
Basically, companies and recruitment agencies
pay LinkedIn to be able to post their jobs
listings on the website and easily reach out
to highly qualified potential recruits.
After Microsoft tookover, we haven’t been
getting as detailed reports about LinkedIn’s
revenue segments, but before they tookover,
talent solutions accounted for almost 2/3s
of LinkedIn’s revenue.
Aside from talent solutions, just like any
other social media platform, LinkedIn also
makes money off of showing ads.
And let me just say, it’s extremely expensive
to market on LinkedIn.
In fact, the average cost of a LinkedIn ad
is $5.26 per click.
For perspective, Google Ads on average only
costs $1 to $2 per click.
So, LinkedIn ads are often 3-5 times more
lucrative than Google Ads.
But with that being said though, people don’t
spend nearly as much time on LinkedIn and
there’s not as many people are who interested
in buying these ads, so ads only account for
18% of their revenue.
And this brings us into LinkedIn’s last
major source of revenue which are premium
subscriptions.
For $30 to $60 per month, LinkedIn users can
unlock additional functionality regarding
job postings and career insights.
To be honest, premium isn’t all that useful
for most LinkedIn users but this has nonetheless
grown to account for 17% of LinkedIn’s revenue
over the years.
Going through all of these sources of revenue,
you probably noticed that one attribute was
extremely apparent, the intent of LinkedIn
is extremely focused.
You go there to advertise about jobs, hire
for jobs, look for jobs, talk about jobs,
spy on other people’s jobs, it’s all about
jobs.
And this is the second factor that makes LinkedIn
more powerful than any other social media:
the intent and focus of LinkedIn is extremely
clear.
With other social media platforms, people
use them for all sorts of reasons from learning
and personal growth to entertainment and comedy.
With LinkedIn, however, there’s only one
reason you use it: something job related.
Other than a few special people, no one actually
uses LinkedIn for fun.
They use LinkedIn with intent and focus whether
its a company, recruiter, or employee.
And given that jobs are the primary way that
the vast majority of the world makes all of
their money, there’s quite a bit money being
exchanged on LinkedIn.
And as such, maintaining and facilitating
this network has also proved to be extremely
lucrative.
LinkedIn first became profitable all the way
back in March of 2006.
For perspective, it took YouTube at least
a decade to achieve profitability and Twitter,
Snapchat, WhatsApp, and TikTok are still not
profitable.
So, LinkedIn is very much the leader when
it comes to revenue and value per user but
not everything about LinkedIn is quite as
rosy.
TOXIC CRINGE:
By 2011, LinkedIn had grown to over a hundred
million users and they were pulling in more
revenue than Twitter.
So, they would decide to make things official
and go public with a valuation of $4.3 billion
in May of 2011.
Let’s just say that this IPO was extremely
successful as the stock market would value
the company at over double that at $8.79 billion
just a few weeks later.
LinkedIn was officially a mainstream platform
but they also started to develop a cringey
reputation.
You see, LinkedIn became the place where people
would overstate their experience and inflate
their job titles in hopes of catching the
eyes of recruiters.
And I’ll be the first to admit that there
is definitely a cringe factor associated with
LinkedIn, but you can say the same thing about
any social media.
With Instagram, for example, you’ve got
a bunch of people chasing clout and portraying
their lives as something better than it is
by posting half naked pictures and highlights
of their otherwise boring lives.
Similarly, with TikTok, you’ve got a bunch
of thirst traps and mindless content that
you wont even remember 10 minutes later.
And even on YouTube, you’ve got a bunch
of clickbait and flexing.
But, there’s one crucial difference between
the cringe of most social medias and the cringe
of LinkedIn.
With most social media, the cringe factor
is a result of people chasing something superficial
whether its the appearance of being rich and
happy or the ego associated with having a
high follower count.
With LinkedIn on the other hand, the cringe
factor is mostly just a result of people wanting
to improve their careers as much as possible.
The bottomline is that people have realized
that staying loyal to one company and working
for 40 years simply doesn’t play out all
that well over the long term.
Even if the company treats you well, it’s
more than likely that your peers who constantly
switched jobs and played the game end up in
a better situation.
More and more people are realizing this with
each passing year leading to more and more
people joining the game on LinkedIn.
Trying to network with as many people as possible,
getting referrals, contacting recruiters,
buffing up profiles and so on.
This of course leads to some pretty cringey
posts and sterile conversations across the
platform, but hey, it’s all done with mostly
good intentions.
Microsoft starting sensing this trend pretty
early on and they basically decided, if you
can’t fight this movement, you might as
well join this movement and profit off it,
and that’s exactly what they did.
In mid 2016, they went ahead and bought out
Linkedin for a $26.2 billion all cash deal.
At the time, Linkedin was pulling in just
under $3 billion per year.
Today, they’re pulling in just under $15
billion per year.
This of course doesn’t directly translate
to market cap growth but I think it’s safe
to say that Linkedin is worth around a $100
billion today.
And this is not surprising when you consider
that they have a billion people using their
platform with the sole focus of career progression,
professional networking, and making more money.
And somehow, this insanely powerful platform
is now also owned by Microsoft.
It’s becoming harder and harder everyday
to escape Microsoft’s stronghold, so maybe
it’s time we adopt their strategy and instead
of fighting them, we join them by investing
in bonds.
If that sounds valuable, check out Silo in
the description below.